رغم تمر ديفاجنر على الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الرئيس بيلاروسي الكسندر
لوكاشينكو يقترح على فاجنر تدريب جنود
بلاده لوكاشينكو قال مرتزقه لكن اذا جاء
مدربوهم ونقلوا لنا خبراتهم القتاليه
فسنقبل بذلك وكاله الانباء البيلاروسيه
اشارت الى كلمه لوكاشينكو الذي القاها في
العاصمه قبل يومين اكد فيها انه لا يخشى
اعضاء مجموعه فاجنر قائلا انهم اناس
قاتلوا في جميع انحاء العالم لتاسيس حضاره
عاديه والغرب يكرههم حتى النخاع وختم
لوكاشينكو كلمته بتحضير من ازمه سياسيه
عسكريه عالميه لم يسبق لها مثيل في تاريخ
البشريه تصريحات لوكاشينكو جاءت بعد نحو
اسبوع من تدخله الناجح في وقف التمرد
المسلح بقوات فاجنر ضد بوتين والذي انتهى
بانسحاب فاجنر ومغادره قائدها